The US has been in Iraq for seven years and I realized the other day, when I heard this clip of tape that I'm about to play you, that I've never even really understood what Baghdad looks like.
美国在伊拉克已经待了七年，前几天我听到一段马上要放给你们听的录音时才意识到，我甚至从未真正理解巴格达是什么样子的。
So what are we looking at?
那么我们到底看到了什么？
Right now, we're here right almost in the geographic center of Baghdad on the fifth floor of a hotel.
此时此刻，我们正位于巴格达的地理中心，在一家酒店的五楼。
This is Larry Kaplow, a journalist who reported from Baghdad for the first six years of the war. He went back this summer, with one of our producers, Nancy Updike. They spent a month in Iraq.
这是拉里·卡普洛（Larry Kaplow），一名在伊拉克战争前六年从巴格达进行报道的记者。今年夏天，他与我们的制片人南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）重返此地。他们在伊拉克待了一个月。
Think of Miami, because it looks like that. It's totally flat and there are lot of palm trees and lots of big highways. And think if you came out of Cutler Ridge or Coral Gables, but it was walled in. Just to drive along a street and have, two feet away from you, you look of the window of your car, you see nothing but wall. It's too tall to even see the top of it out your car window. You just looked out and you see wall segment, wall segment, wall segment.
想象一下迈阿密，因为这里看起来就像那样。它完全是平坦的，有很多棕榈树和许多宽阔的高速公路。想象一下你从卡特勒岭（Cutler Ridge）或珊瑚阁（Coral Gables）出来，但四周都被围墙围住了。你沿着街道行驶，从车窗向外望去，离你两英尺远的地方，除了墙什么也看不见。墙太高了，连车窗都看不到墙顶。你只能向外看，看到一段墙、又一段墙，连绵不断。
So it's like Miami, except these concrete blast walls that honeycomb the city, 12 feet tall, giant great dominoes, thousands of them, creating a kind of endless maze. They fully enclose entire neighborhoods. Which means that to run errands, or go to your job, or do anything normal outside your own neighborhood, you go through checkpoints each time you cross from one place to another, over and over. Even the soldiers at the checkpoints find these checkpoints so depressing that lots of them are decorated with fake flowers, bleached by the sun, in strands and bunches.
所以这里就像迈阿密，只是城市里布满了12英尺高、巨大的多米诺骨牌般的混凝土防爆墙，成千上万块墙体形成了一种无尽的迷宫。它们将整个街区完全封闭。这意味着要处理杂务、去上班，或者在自己社区外做任何正常的事情，每次你从一个地方穿行到另一个地方时，都必须穿过检查站，一次又一次。即便是检查站的士兵也觉得这些哨卡令人压抑，所以许多哨卡用太阳晒得发白的假花串和花束装饰着。
Now the other thing about the way the city looks, Larry says, and he's back in the States. He's actually sitting right here with me in the studio, is that with Saddam Hussein gone, Baghdad is now clearly a Shiite city. It's been majority Shiite for generations, but you couldn't tell before Saddam fell, because Saddam led a regime dominated by the Sunnis, and they tried to paper over the religious differences between the two groups.
关于这座城市的样貌，拉里说——他现在已经回到了美国，此刻正坐在演播室和我在一起——随着萨达姆·侯赛因的倒台，巴格达现在显然已经是一座什叶派城市了。几十年来，这里一直以什叶派为主，但在萨达姆倒台前你根本看不出来，因为萨达姆领导的政权由逊尼派主导，他们试图掩盖这两个群体之间的宗教差异。
But that changed, the day the US invaded, right?
但美国入侵的那天起，情况就变了，对吧？
Right. I was there and within hours after the regime fell, we immediately saw people putting up the Shiite flags, the satiny all black, all red, all green banners going up on houses, offices, mosques. Along with these portraits or icons of Shiite figures. And it was like suddenly there was this whole other geography of the city. A place we thought of before as like, OK, this is just a poor neighborhood, suddenly it's like, wow, this is like a really-- this is all Shiite. And then you go to the other, richer neighborhoods and they don't have any flags here. These must be the Sunni engineers and professors who were in the regime. And it really changed your whole sense of geography of the city.
没错。我在现场，政权倒台后短短几个小时内，我们就立即看到人们在房屋、办公室和清真寺上悬挂什叶派旗帜，那些绸缎般的纯黑、全红、全绿的横幅。随之出现的还有什叶派人物的肖像或圣像。突然之间，这座城市呈现出完全不同的地理面貌。以前我们认为“好吧，这只是一个贫民区”，突然变成了“哇，这真是……这里全是什叶派”。然后你去到其他更富裕的街区，那里没有任何旗帜。这些一定是政权中的逊尼派工程师和教授。这真的改变了你对这座城市地理分布的整体感觉。
And let's just review before we say anything else about Iraq. Shia versus Sunni.
在我们谈论伊拉克的其他情况之前，先复习一下。什叶派与逊尼派。
Well, it's a big over simplification, but one way to think about it is that they're like Protestants and Catholics. Shiites being like the Catholics. They have a hierarchy of Priests or Imams leading all the way up to Ayatollahs and Grand-Ayatollahs the way Catholics have a hierarchy of priests leading all the way up to the Vatican and the Pope. They have much more of an emphasis on rituals, on icons, on what we call saints, their religious leaders throughout the centuries.
这是一个很大的简化，但可以这样想：他们就像新教徒和天主教徒。什叶派就像天主教徒，他们有通往阿亚图拉（Ayatollah）和大阿亚图拉的牧师或伊玛目等级制度，就像天主教有通往梵蒂冈和教皇的祭司等级制度一样。他们更强调仪式、圣像，以及我们所说的圣徒，即他们历代的宗教领袖。
And Sunni doesn't have that?
逊尼派没有吗？
The Sunni don't have that. And some Sunni will say the Shia are not focused enough just on Mohammed and God, that they've created this assortment of religious leadership. They would look at Shia and say, they're are too showy. I don't need to show off my religion like that. The same way some Protestants will look at Catholics and say that and sort of turn up their nose at that.
逊尼派没有。有些逊尼派会说，什叶派对穆罕默德和安拉关注不够，他们创造了一系列宗教领导层。他们看待什叶派时会说，他们太爱炫耀了。我不必那样展示我的宗教。就像一些新教徒看天主教徒时也会那样想，并对此嗤之以鼻一样。
Now, the Sunnis are the minority in Iraq. Saddam Hussein was Sunni. And now that he's out, the overwhelming majority of the country, the Shia, are in control. In the past in Iraq, Shia and Sunni lived side by side and they inter-married. Since the invasion, as we've all heard, there have been been periods of Sunni and Shia killing each other. So, today are they're getting along?
现在，逊尼派在伊拉克是少数派。萨达姆·侯赛因是逊尼派。而现在他倒台了，占国家绝大多数的什叶派掌握了控制权。在过去的伊拉克，什叶派和逊尼派并肩生活，甚至通婚。自入侵以来，正如我们所听到的，曾出现过逊尼派和什叶派互相残杀的时期。那么今天，他们相处得如何？
Well, Nancy Updike, who was in Iraq with Larry is also in the studio. Nancy, how is it going?
南希·厄普代克和拉里一起在伊拉克，她也在演播室。南希，情况怎么样？
Well, Larry and I talked to this Shiite guy, he's an educated man, a professor, you've known him for years, right Larry?
拉里和我采访了一位什叶派人士，他是一位受过教育的人，一位教授，拉里你认识他很多年了，对吧？
Right, I have. Although he still didn't feel safe to be speaking to Americans on the radio, so he didn't want to be identified. I just wanted you to meet him and hear him talk about daily life. Like he told us that his salary which was $3 a month before Saddam fell is now $1,000 a month. And that's very typical for people now, to have more money.
是的，认识。尽管他仍然觉得在广播里向美国人说话不太安全，所以他不想透露身份。我只是想让你见见他，听他谈谈日常生活。比如他告诉我们，他在萨达姆倒台前每月工资是3美元，现在是每月1000美元。现在人们拥有更多钱是很普遍的。
On the other hand, he told us that he has to go through 10 checkpoints every morning to get to school. The trip used to take 15 minutes, now it can take an hour or two. And then, in the middle of this, as we were talking to him about his life, I was surprised because people don't usually talk about this so openly, he goes into the tension between Sunni and Shia.
另一方面，他告诉我们，他每天早上为了去学校得经过10个检查站。这段路以前只需要15分钟，现在可能需要一到两个小时。然后，正当我们和他谈论他的生活时，我很惊讶，因为人们通常不会如此公开地谈论这些，他谈到了逊尼派和什叶派之间的紧张关系。
We have not recovered fully. We are still in the recovery period.
我们还没有完全恢复。我们仍处于恢复期。
So he's Shia, he's got Sunni friends, he has a Sunni girlfriend. And he told us this story about a Sunni friend of his who owed him $200. And they were going to lunch to settle up this debt. The professor suggested a fish restaurant in a Shiite neighborhood, that would be safe and comfortable for him. And the friend, the Sunni friend, wanted to go to a neighborhood called Al Adhamiya. Just a year ago, the professor would never have gone to this neighborhood. It just would have been too dangerous. But he let himself get talked into it.
所以他是什叶派，他有逊尼派朋友，他还有个逊尼派女朋友。他给我们讲了一个故事，关于他的一位欠他200美元的逊尼派朋友。他们打算去吃午饭并偿还这笔债务。教授建议去一家什叶派社区的鱼餐馆，对他来说那会更安全、更舒适。但那位朋友，那位逊尼派朋友，想去一个叫阿达米亚（Al Adhamiya）的社区。就在一年前，教授绝不会去那个社区，因为太危险了。但他还是被说服了。
So we were there, in a restaurant, invited by him, to tell the truth. At that time, sitting in that restaurant, I had my concerns.
所以我们就在那里，在他邀请下去了那家餐馆，说实话，当时坐在那家餐馆里，我确实有所顾虑。
You didn't feel safe?
你感到不安全吗？
Yes, of course. Because I am Shiite. For a Shiite to be in Al Adhamiya, it is a danger. And a big danger. By the way, my family blamed me. "You go for such a place. And alone? Why should you have gone to such of place, and alone?" I told them, but he's my friend. Even though, do not trust him.
是的，当然。因为我是什叶派。对于什叶派来说，身处阿达米亚是一种危险，而且是巨大的危险。顺便说一下，我的家人责备我，“你竟然去那种地方，还独自一人？你为什么要独自去那种地方？”我告诉他们，他是我的朋友。尽管如此，还是不要信任他。
So the professor is sitting there with his Sunni friend in this pizza restaurant, this is all just a few months ago, and he's trying to keep the conversation on politically neutral subjects. How things are going at the university. And then an Iraqi army convoy passed in front of the restaurant's window, and his friend watched the convoy pass, and made a comment.
所以教授坐在那家披萨店里和他那位逊尼派朋友在一起，这都是几个月前的事了，他试图让谈话保持在政治中立的话题上。比如学校的情况怎么样。然后一支伊拉克军队的车队经过餐馆窗前，他的朋友看着车队经过，发表了评论。
He said, "OK, when the Americans will withdraw their last soldier here from Iraq, we, the National Resistance--"
他说，“好吧，当美国人从伊拉克撤走最后一名士兵时，我们，国民抵抗力量……”
The National Resistance meaning the Sunni insurgency--
国民抵抗力量是指逊尼派叛乱分子……
"--will restore things to normalcy." Normalcy for him means that they should be in the lead.
“……将恢复秩序。”对他来说，秩序意味着他们应该处于领导地位。
Sunnis should be in power. Like they were in Saddam's day.
逊尼派应该掌权。就像他们在萨达姆时期那样。
I just, you know, gave him a fake smile, which was not real and OK-- and then he says, "Why don't you claim you are Sunni? Not say I'm Shiite. Because your thoughts are very nice. And your thoughts are in conformity with ours. Always, do not ever say I am Shiite." Now in Iraq there is  a freedom of speech, but still, we have to, you know, we have to be careful when speaking. In Iraq now there is a big division.
我只是，你知道，对他露出了一个虚假的微笑，那不是真实的，好吧——然后他说，“你为什么不声称你是逊尼派？不要说我是什叶派。因为你的想法非常好，而且你的想法和我们是一致的。永远，永远不要说我是什叶派。”现在在伊拉克有言论自由，但仍然，我们必须，你知道，说话时必须小心。在伊拉克，现在分歧很大。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass. This August, when the United States declared an end to combat operations in Iraq and pulled back its troops, officially lowered the numbers to under 50,000, one of the things you didn't get very much in the coverage is that you didn't hear many Iraqi voices. So Nancy and Larry spent a month in Iraq and talked to lots of people. Because we wanted to understand, with the US pulling back finally, how are things going? How well is the country emerging from the war? How are people feeling? What's Iraq going to be like, after us. That's our show today, in three acts, stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，节目由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今年八月，当美国宣布结束在伊拉克的作战行动并撤回部队，官方将人数降至5万人以下时，报道中你没有听到太多伊拉克人的声音。所以南希和拉里在伊拉克待了一个月，与许多人交谈。因为我们想了解，随着美国最终撤出，情况如何？这个国家从战争中恢复得如何？人们感觉如何？我们离开后，伊拉克会变成什么样？这就是我们今天的节目，分为三幕，请继续收听。
Act One, What Just Happened? Lots of us understand it's still kind of a mess in Iraq right now, but the specifics of that mess are a little vague. And, to get a grip on that, let's start with the story of one man, and everything that this one man has seen since the invasion. The man's named Abu Abed. Nancy tells this story.
第一幕，刚才发生了什么？我们很多人都知道伊拉克现在还是很混乱，但混乱的具体情况有点模糊。为了掌握这一点，让我们从一个人的故事开始，以及他自入侵以来所看到的一切。这个人叫阿布·阿贝德（Abu Abed）。南希来讲这个故事。
Here's what I knew about Abu Abed when I met him. He was an Iraqi who had fought with the Americans in Baghdad during the surge, and he'd become a small legend. The game changer who help the US drive al-Qaeda out of one of the most dangerous neighborhoods in Baghdad.
这是我遇到阿布·阿贝德时对他的了解。他是一位在“增兵”期间曾在巴格达与美国人并肩作战的伊拉克人，他成了一位小传奇。那个帮助美军将基地组织赶出巴格达最危险社区之一的破局者。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: Probably the bravest man I ever met.
库尔上校（COLONEL DALE KUEHL）：他可能是我见过的最勇敢的人。
This is Colonel Dale Kuehl. The US commander of the area in Baghdad where Abu Abed fought al-Qaeda.
这是戴尔·库尔（Dale Kuehl）上校。美军在巴格达阿布·阿贝德与基地组织作战区域的指挥官。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: He confronted them face to face on the street. How many people can say they did that? Stood up to al-Qaeda when they were controlling a town like that? Where 16 American soldiers died in one month.
库尔上校：他在街上与他们面对面交锋。有多少人能说自己做到了这一点？在基地组织控制那样一个城镇时站出来反抗他们？在一个月内就有16名美国士兵丧生。
Two years after helping the US route al-Qaeda in Iraq, Abu Abed was living like a fugitive. A suicide bomber tried to kill him in Baghdad, and he and his family fled Iraq for Jordan. It didn't help. They had to change addresses every couple of months. Abu Abed was attacked in the street. They were getting death threats from al-Qaeda, including a note handed to his son at school. His wife was stabbed during an attempt kidnap their son. A few days before I got in touch with him, Abu Abed paid a smuggler $50,000 to get him, his wife, and their two children to Sweden.
在帮助美军清除伊拉克基地组织两年后，阿布·阿贝德像个逃犯一样生活。一名自杀式炸弹袭击者曾试图在巴格达杀死他，他和家人逃往约旦。但这没用。他们不得不每隔几个月更换住址。阿布·阿贝德在街上遭到袭击。他们收到了来自基地组织的死亡威胁，包括一张递给他上学儿子的纸条。他的妻子在一次绑架儿子的企图中心部被刺伤。在我联系他之前几天，阿布·阿贝德付给蛇头5万美元，才让他、他的妻子和他们的两个孩子逃往瑞典。
Abu Abed, whose real name is Saad Oraibi Ghaffouri Al-Obeidi, has letters full of praise from American generals saying he should be allowed to come to the US. General David Petraeus, former top commander of the war, wrote one for him. But America turned him down flat, no explanation, even now. Abu Abed sits on the edge of a couch, unshaven, in cropped khaki pants, khaki shirt, and sandals.
阿布·阿贝德，原名萨阿德·奥拉伊比·加富里·奥贝迪（Saad Oraibi Ghaffouri Al-Obeidi），拥有许多美国将军的表彰信，称他应该被允许进入美国。前战争最高指挥官大卫·彼得雷乌斯（David Petraeus）将军曾为他写过一封。但美国断然拒绝了他，没有给出任何理由。即便到现在，阿布·阿贝德仍然坐在沙发边缘，未剃胡须，穿着剪裁过的卡其裤、卡其衬衫和凉鞋。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
We were told to go to the embassy, where I waited in hall, fully expecting to be granted my visa. And they said, you've been denied. It's a final decision. I couldn't believe it. I felt like I'd just gotten a bullet in the head.
我们被告知去大使馆，我在大厅里等着，完全期待着签证获批。但他们说，你被拒签了。这是最终决定。我简直不敢相信。我觉得自己就像脑袋上挨了一颗子弹。
Sweden is still deciding whether he can stay.
瑞典仍在决定他是否可以留下。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
They asked me, well, here you have these recommendations, highest ranking American military personnel, why aren't you in America? How haven't they taken you to America? And I don't know what to say.
他们问我，好吧，你有这些最高级别美国军方的推荐，为什么你不在美国？他们怎么没把你带到美国？我不知道该说什么。
The Iraq war has had one question at its heart, with an answer that keeps shifting, who is our enemy? Abu Abed has gone from being a central character in US strategy to an exile sleeping on a friend's floor. And those are only two of the roles he's played in the Iraq war. At every turn in the war, every change in US tactics or strategy, Abu Abed has been there, either benefiting or getting pounded. He's a living catalog of the seven years of decisions, successes and failures, that have made up this war.
伊拉克战争的核心一直有一个问题，答案不断变化：谁是我们的敌人？阿布·阿贝德从美国战略的核心人物变成了睡在朋友地板上的流亡者。而这些只是他在伊拉克战争中扮演的两个角色。在战争的每一个转折点，在美军战术或战略的每一次改变中，阿布·阿贝德都在那里，要么获益，要么受挫。他是这场战争七年来决策、成功与失败的活字典。
During the first phase of the war, Abu Abed was our enemy. He was a captain in Saddam Hussein's air force. In intelligence, he says. His country was being invaded. Then the war very quickly entered its second phase, the insurgency. IEDs, car bombs, sniper attacks. The insurgency was led by Sunnis, many of them former Iraqi army officers. Abu Abed was a Sunni and a former Iraqi army officer. But he insists he was never part of that. He never fought the US. I asked him about it so many times, he got exasperated.
战争的第一阶段，阿布·阿贝德是我们的敌人。他是萨达姆·侯赛因空军的一名上尉。他说他是在情报部门。他的国家正在被入侵。随后战争很快进入了第二阶段，即叛乱时期。简易爆炸装置（IED）、汽车炸弹、狙击手袭击。叛乱由逊尼派领导，其中许多是前伊拉克军官。阿布·阿贝德是逊尼派，也是前伊拉克军官。但他坚持说他从未参与其中。他从未与美军作战。我问过他很多次，他变得恼火了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
If I wanted to, I could get up and say that I fought the Americans. I could take pride in the fact that I fought the occupation, and I would be able to win many people's respect in Iraq and in the region. But it's just not true.
如果我想的话，我可以站出来说我对抗过美国人。我可以因为反抗占领而感到自豪，并且能在伊拉克和该地区赢得许多人的尊重。但这根本不是事实。
This has been Abu Abed's official position for years, so it's hard for him to back off it. But a US army captain, who later befriended him says Abu Abed told him the truth. He did fight the US, he was part of the insurgency. But to make things even more complicated, he was also reaching out to the US, as early as 2004, feeding them information. Like any smart gambler, he was placing more than one bet. In this early stage of the war, the insurgency, one of the coalition force's main tactics was raid, arrest, interrogate. Which happened to Abu Abed. He was picked up in a neighborhood sweep.
多年来，这是阿布·阿贝德的官方立场，所以他很难退缩。但一位后来与他成为朋友的美国陆军上尉说，阿布·阿贝德告诉了他真相。他的确与美军作战过，他是叛乱的一部分。但让事情变得更加复杂的是，早在2004年，他就开始接触美军，向他们提供情报。就像任何聪明的赌徒一样，他在押注不止一处。在战争的这一早期阶段，即叛乱时期，联军的主要战术之一是搜捕、逮捕和审讯。这正好发生在了阿布·阿贝德身上。他在一次街区搜查中被带走了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Soldiers came in, translator told me to put my face to the wall. I said, "What's going on here?" He said, "Just put your face up against the wall."
士兵们进来，翻译让我面朝墙壁。我说，“这里发生了什么？”他说，“把脸贴在墙上就行。”
I confirmed with another US officer that Abu Abed was arrested early in the war. Abu Abed says he was interrogated by American civilians, private contractors.
我从另一位美国军官那里证实，阿布·阿贝德在战争初期确实被捕过。阿布·阿贝德说他受到美国平民，即私人承包商的审讯。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
I was put in a room where I was hung by my arms. I couldn't sit down, I couldn't rest, all the time with a bag over my head. For days I was dying of thirst for water. They wouldn't let me drink, they would just pour the water on my face. They wouldn't let me drink from it.
我被带到一个房间，双手被吊起来。我不能坐下，不能休息，头上一直套着袋子。好几天了，我渴得要死。他们不让我喝水，只是把水倒在我脸上。他们不让我喝。
Abu Abed says the civilian interrogators held him for around 20 days. They were insisting they knew who he was. They kept calling him a name he remembers as something like "Shaddat," and they wanted him to admit it. Nothing he said could convince them otherwise. Abu Abed says the torture and interrogation ended when he was suddenly switched to a different room.
阿布·阿贝德说，那些平民审讯员关了他大约20天。他们坚称知道他是谁。他们一直叫他一个他记得发音类似“沙达特”（Shaddat）的名字，他们要他承认。无论他说什么都无法说服他们。阿布·阿贝德说，酷刑和审讯在他突然被转到另一个房间时结束了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Given a bed. Given a TV with a DVD player and DVDs. They asked me, what kind of movies would you like to watch? I said, I like Sylvester Stalone movies and Arnold Schwarzenegger movies. So they brought me a bunch of those movies. And they said, "Listen, we're very, very sorry. But we have discovered it's true, that you're not Shaddat." They said, "Please, you know, we WERE looking for this person and we realize we made a mistake with you." And I said, "No. I can appreciate that. I understand what the problem is." And he said, "So we're friends?" And I said, "Yeah, we're friends."
给了我一张床。给了我一台带有DVD播放器和光盘的电视。他们问我，你想看什么电影？我说，我喜欢西尔维斯特·史泰龙和阿诺德·施瓦辛格的电影。于是他们带给我一堆那种电影。他们说，“听着，我们非常非常抱歉。但我们发现那是真的，你不是沙达特。”他们说，“请，你知道，我们确实在找那个人，我们意识到搞错了。”我说，“不。我很感激。我理解问题出在哪。”他说，“所以我们是朋友了？”我说，“是的，我们是朋友。”
By 2006, the war had changed again. Many Iraqis now refer to that early insurgency as the "Honorable resistance," to distinguish it from what happened next. Iraq turned into a sectarian war that was basically a gang war. Sunni gangs, often allied with al-Qaeda, versus Shiite gangs. And if you were a regular person, trying to live your life and weren't in one of the gangs yourself, the differences between them seemed mainly stylistic. One man told us, "The way you know al-Qaeda is coming up to your house to kill you, is that their addressed like ordinary guys, and shouting "Allah hu akbar." The way you know a Shiite militia is pulling up to your house, is that they're dressed all in black, and shouting the names of Shiite saints.
到了2006年，战争再次改变。许多伊拉克人现在称早期的叛乱为“光荣的抵抗”，以区别于后来发生的事情。伊拉克变成了宗派战争，基本上是帮派战争。逊尼派帮派，通常与基地组织结盟，对抗什叶派帮派。如果你是一个试图过日子、不属于任何帮派的普通人，它们之间的区别主要体现在风格上。一个人告诉我们：“如果你看到基地组织接近你的房子要杀你，你会发现他们像普通人一样穿着，大喊‘安拉至大’。如果是一个什叶派民兵接近你的房子，你会发现他们穿着全黑的衣服，大喊什叶派圣徒的名字。”
Abu Abed's neighborhood in Baghdad, Amiriyah, is a Sunni stronghold. A place where members of Saddam's military got nice houses and had lived well back in the day. Some Sunnis in Abu Abed's neighborhood joined forces with al-Qaeda against their common enemies. The Shiite militias and the Americans. In fact, at the height of its power, al-Qaeda declared Amiriyah its capital. They appointed their own finance minister, education minister. The new Iraqi government was desperate.
阿布·阿贝德在巴格达的社区阿米里亚（Amiriyah）是逊尼派据点。在那里，萨达姆军队的成员曾拥有漂亮的房子，过去生活富足。阿布·阿贝德社区的一些逊尼派与基地组织联手对抗他们共同的敌人：什叶派民兵和美国人。事实上，在基地组织权力巅峰时期，他们宣布阿米里亚为首都。他们任命了自己的财政部长、教育部长。新的伊拉克政府感到绝望。
2006, we virtually lost control over Baghdad.
2006年，我们几乎失去了对巴格达的控制。
This is Saad Motallebi, an adviser in the current Iraqi government.
这是萨阿德·莫塔勒比（Saad Motallebi），现任伊拉克政府顾问。
We were completely surrounded. They had control of many areas in Baghdad, and the Americans didn't know what to do. And 2006, 2007, we were seriously worried.
我们被完全包围了。他们在巴格达许多地区拥有控制权，美国人不知道该怎么办。2006年、2007年，我们非常担心。
But then something changed. People started to hate al-Qaeda. In Amiriyah, al-Qaeda kidnapped and brutally killed an older Christian couple who everyone liked. Abu Abed saw a friend whipped in the street.
但随后情况发生了变化。人们开始憎恨基地组织。在阿米里亚，基地组织绑架并残酷杀害了一对大家都喜欢的年长基督徒夫妇。阿布·阿贝德亲眼目睹了一位朋友在街上被鞭打。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
They would whip a person, strip him of his clothes, and then whip him either with a whip or a stick. Cut off a person's hand, they would cut out a person's tongue. They forced every female teacher to, if she wasn't wearing a hijab, she'd be executed.
他们会鞭打一个人，剥光他的衣服，然后用鞭子或棍子抽他。砍掉人的手，割掉人的舌头。他们强迫每一位女教师，如果她不戴头巾，就会被处决。
Al-Qaeda went into Iraq seeing themselves as liberators, overplayed their hand, and alienated people. And that's when the American forces and the Iraqi government got their big break. The sons of Iraq, also sometimes called the Awakening or the Sunni Awakening.
基地组织进入伊拉克时自视为解放者，但用力过猛，导致民心尽失。就在那时，美军和伊拉克政府得到了最大的突破。“伊拉克之子”，有时也被称为“觉醒”运动或“逊尼派觉醒”。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: The Sons of Iraq was a very decentralized organization. In fact, calling it an organization is probably not the right way.
库尔上校：伊拉克之子是一个非常分散的组织。事实上，称其为组织可能并不准确。
This is Colonel Kuehl again, whose area of command included Amiriyah. Before the Sons of Iraq showed up, the US had been focusing, for years, on a failed plan, recruiting and training the Iraqi army and police to get them able to secure the country. When they stand up, we will stand down. It wasn't working. In fact, it was making things worse. The police force we were building, which is overwhelmingly Shiite, had pockets of Shiite militias who would kidnap and kill people, often without bothering to change out of their uniforms. Abu Abed says two of his brothers were killed by a Shiite militia.
又是库尔上校，他的指挥区包括阿米里亚。在“伊拉克之子”出现之前，美军多年来一直专注于一个失败的计划：招募和训练伊拉克军队和警察，让他们有能力保卫国家。“他们站起来，我们就退下去。”但这没用。事实上，这让情况变得更糟。我们建立的警察部队绝大多数是什叶派，其中混杂着什叶派民兵，他们会绑架和杀害平民，往往连制服都不换。阿布·阿贝德说他的两个兄弟被什叶派民兵杀了。
In Amiriyah, the Sons of Iraq started in late May, 2007, when Colonel Kuehl got a phone call from a local leader, a Sheikh and an Imam, who Kuehl had chewed out 10 days earlier, following an IED attack on his men. Kuehl had told them, "You have to help us fight al-Qaeda."
在阿米里亚，“伊拉克之子”始于2007年5月下旬，当时库尔上校接到了一位当地领导人——一位谢赫兼伊玛目——的电话，库尔曾在10天前因其手下遭遇简易爆炸装置袭击而训斥过他。库尔曾对他们说：“你们必须帮助我们打击基地组织。”
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: Calls me, it was in the middle of the night, and says, "Hey, we're going after al-Qaeda tomorrow." And I'm like, you're going to do what? He says, we're going after al-Qaeda tomorrow, we just want you to stay away. We just want you to stay out here. And I said Sheikh, I can't do that. I can't leave the neighborhood. We argued for about 20 minutes. I said, give me the intelligence, we'll go after it. He said, "No, it won't work. We've got to do it ourselves."
库尔上校：半夜给我打电话，说：“嘿，我们明天要去找基地组织算账。”我说，你们要干什么？他说，我们明天要对基地组织采取行动，我们只想让你离远点。我想让你待在这儿外面。我说谢赫，我不能那样做。我不能离开社区。我们争论了大约20分钟。我说，把情报给我，我们会去行动。他说：“不，那样不行。我们必须自己动手。”
We will shoot at you.
我们会向你开火。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: We will shoot you. I think literally I said, "We'll kill you." He said, OK. And then I wished him luck.
库尔上校：我们会向你开火。我想我当时简直是说：“我们会杀了你。”他说，好吧。然后我祝他好运。
What followed was a quick initial victory and then a furious counter attack by al-Qaeda. The Imam called Kuehl for help, and the US forces went in and pushed al-Qaeda back, and then--
随后是一场快速的初步胜利，紧接着是基地组织的疯狂反扑。伊玛目打电话向库尔求援，美军进入并击退了基地组织，然后……
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: That's when the negotiation started. On how are we going to do this? I got a call from another Imam, I would say who is probably the most influential in the neighborhood, and he said, "OK, there's someone that you need to meet." And so that's when I met Abu Abed. One of the strangest experiences of my life. Because I'm in there with guys who look like insurgents. It was out at the mosque we met. And he was exhausted and the first meeting didn't go so well. He was making demands, that I'm like, "nope, we ain't going to do that."
库尔上校：那就是谈判开始的时候。我们该怎么做？我接到了另一位伊玛目的电话，我想他可能是社区里最有影响力的人，他说：“好吧，有个人你需要见见。”于是我见到了阿布·阿贝德。这是我一生中最奇怪的经历之一。因为我当时正和那些看起来像叛乱分子的人在一起。我们在清真寺见面。他筋疲力尽，第一次会面并不太顺利。他提出了一些要求，我当时说：“不，我们不会那样做。”
What were his demands?
他提出了什么要求？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: He was saying, if you just let us do what we need to do, we'll clear this place out. Basically free rein to take care of business. That was a bit much. Their point to me was that the US Army and the Iraqi Army could not do it without their help. And it was a humbling experience, someone telling me, what do you mean you know I'm--
库尔上校：他说，如果你只让我们做我们需要做的事，我们会清理这个地方。基本上是让他自由地处理生意。那太过分了。他们的观点是，没有他们的帮助，美军和伊拉克军队无法完成任务。那是一种谦卑的经历，有人告诉我，你什么意思你以为我是……
I'm the US Army.
我是美国陆军。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: I'm the US Army, I can do anything. But he was right. We could not do it alone.
库尔上校：我是美国陆军，我可以做任何事。但他是对的。我们无法独自完成。
And this was Abu Abed saying this to you?
这就是阿布·阿贝德对你说的？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: That's correct.
库尔上校：没错。
Each Sons of Iraq group developed its own working arrangement with the US military in the area. When Abu Abed and Kuehl joined forces, they signed a memorandum of agreement, which was also signed by the Iraqi army commander in the area. The deal was Abu Abed and his men had to coordinate their operations with the US military and the Iraqi Army. No going off on their own.
每个“伊拉克之子”组织都与该地区的美军形成了自己的工作安排。当阿布·阿贝德和库尔联手时，他们签署了一份谅解备忘录，该备忘录也由该地区的伊拉克军队指挥官签署。协议规定，阿布·阿贝德和他的手下必须与美军及伊拉克军队协调行动，不能擅自行动。
Anyone they detained had to be turned over to the US, at first within 24 hours, later within two hours. No torture. All the fighters had to be fingerprinted and given and eye scan. In return, Abu Abed got an office, four pick-up trucks. They all got uniforms. The US paid them about $300 a month, and promised to help them get jobs later. Abu Abed commanded a shifting group of men that, at one point, numbered several hundred. Overall, the Sons of Iraq was a total of 103,000 people countrywide at its height. A huge boost to the American forces, who numbered 170,000 in 2007.
任何被拘留的人都必须移交给美军，起初在24小时内，后来在两小时内。禁止折磨。所有战士都必须按指纹并进行虹膜扫描。作为回报，阿布·阿贝德得到了一间办公室、四辆皮卡车。他们都得到了制服。美军每月支付他们大约300美元，并承诺以后帮助他们找工作。阿布·阿贝德指挥着一群不断变动的人，一度达到了几百人。总体而言，“伊拉克之子”在鼎盛时期全国总人数达到10.3万人。这对美军来说是一个巨大的助推，美军在2007年有17万人。
This is the most successful phase of the Iraq war. The part we've come to shorthand as the surge. What this meant in Abu Abed's case was that the same men who'd fought the Americans, who've been picked up and tortured by coalition forces three years earlier, had reached out to the US military and was now working with them every day.
这是伊拉克战争最成功的一个阶段。我们简称为“增兵”的部分。在阿布·阿贝德的情况下，这意味着曾与美国人作战、三年前被联军逮捕并折磨过的人，现在接触了美军，每天与他们并肩工作。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
You're having a soda on top of a US tank.
你正坐在美国坦克上喝苏打水。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Abu Abed has dozens of photographing from his time fighting alongside the US military. The photos were among the few things he insisted on bringing with him when the family was smuggled to Sweden. In the photos, Abu Abed is leaner than he is now, with a mustache. He looks relaxed and energized. A man whose talents are in demand. The more he shuffles through the photos, the happier he gets, telling war stories.
阿布·阿贝德保留了几十张他与美军并肩作战的照片。当全家被偷渡到瑞典时，这些照片是他坚持随身携带的少数物品之一。照片中的阿布·阿贝德比现在瘦，留着胡子。他看起来放松且充满活力。一个才华受到追捧的人。他翻阅照片越久，就越快乐，讲着战争故事。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
There was a time when we went right into a al-Qaeda hide out, and bullets were flying from every direction, flying at us.
曾有一段时间，我们直接冲进基地组织的巢穴，子弹从四面八方飞向我们。
It's a most animated I ever see him.
这是我见过他最活跃的时候。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Every American we talked to who fought with Abu Abed said he was an incredible soldier. One, Captain Brian Weightman, described his as fluid. That 1% who can remain calm in the middle of hair-raising chaos, able to inspire men, Weightman said, including him. Some Americans called him a brother. Once the Americans embraced the Sons of Iraq, it forced the Iraqi Army to work with them. And in Amiriyah, the three groups together were an unstoppable force against al-Qaeda. In the midst of this triumphant military campaign, in which Abu Abed was a crucial partner, trusted every day with American lives, two US captains Abu Abed worked with came to him and said they'd been told to take him to some meeting with some people. So Abu Abed went to the meeting, not thinking much of it.
每一个我们交谈过的与阿布·阿贝德并肩作战的美国人都说他是一名不可思议的士兵。一位布莱恩·韦特曼（Brian Weightman）上尉形容他很“灵活”。那是那1%能在毛骨悚然的混乱中保持冷静、能激励手下（包括他自己在内）的人。一些美国人称他为兄弟。一旦美国人拥抱了“伊拉克之子”，就迫使伊拉克军队与他们合作。而在阿米里亚，这三个群体联手成为了对付基地组织不可阻挡的力量。在这场凯旋的军事行动中，阿布·阿贝德是至关重要的伙伴，每天都被托付美国人的生命，有两名与他共事的美国上尉来到他面前，说他们接到命令带他去见一些人。于是阿布·阿贝德没多想就去参加了会议。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(SUBJECT) TRANSLATOR: And they open the door, and I saw this group of people that said they wanted to meet me. And I instantly new who they were. I  knew exactly who they were.
翻译：他们打开门，我看到了那群说想见我的人。我瞬间就知道他们是谁了。我清楚地知道他们是谁。
It was the group of civilians who had interrogated him in 2004. The same people he says beat him, hung him from his arms, and held him captive for as long as they wanted. Those same people were now smiling at him, and saying how glad they were to see them. Abu Abed tried to stay calm.
那是2004年审讯他的平民小组。就是那些他说殴打他、将他双手悬吊并随心所欲拘禁他的人。现在，同样的那群人正对他微笑着，说着见到他有多高兴。阿布·阿贝德试图保持冷静。
They asked me if I remember them, and I said, "No, I don't know who you are. I don't remember you." Because I was so hurt I said I don't remember you, even though, of course, I did. And they said, "Well, we forget the past, right? We're friends now. Are you sure you don't remember us?" "Yeah, I don't know who you are," I said. Then they opened up a laptop with a picture of me, and they said, "well, who's this?" And that picture of me with a number across my chest, the number of me when I was captive.
他们问我是否记得他们，我说，“不，我不知道你是谁。我不记得你了。”因为我太痛苦了，所以说我不记得，尽管我当然记得。他们打开一台笔记本电脑，上面有我的照片，他们说，“好吧，这是谁？”那张照片里我胸前贴着编号，我被囚禁时的编号。
I spoke with one of the captains who sat in the room, not really understanding what was going on, who these people were to Abu Abed. The captain said there were other photos on the laptop, too, like a book of mug shots. Fighters the US was looking for, and the interrogators seem to be asking Abu Abed if he knew anything about them.
我和其中一位坐在房间里的上尉交谈，他当时并不真正了解发生了什么，以及这些人对阿布·阿贝德意味着什么。上尉说笔记本电脑上还有其他照片，像一本嫌疑人档案。美国正在寻找的战士，审讯员似乎在问阿布·阿贝德是否知道关于他们的任何信息。
But all Abu Abed could focus on was his own picture. Why did they show that to him? Either it was a threat, help us or else, or maybe to the interrogators the torture of three years earlier was such ancient history that they didn't think it would matter. That was yesterday, we're friends now.
但阿布·阿贝德满脑子想的只有他自己的照片。为什么要给他看那个？要么是一种威胁：帮我们，否则……或者对审讯员来说，三年前的酷刑已经是太古老的历史，他们认为无关紧要。那是昨天的事，我们现在是朋友。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(SUBJECT) TRANSLATOR: I started asking myself all kinds of questions. All kinds of questions were spinning around in my head. I wanted to know how did they see me? What was I in their eyes? Was I a terrorist? Is that how they perceived me? I feel incredibly wronged. But I didn't know what the point was.
翻译：我开始问自己各种各样的问题。各种问题在我脑海中盘旋。我想知道他们是怎么看我的？在他们眼里我算什么？我是恐怖分子吗？他们就是这样认为的吗？我感到受到了极大的冤枉。但我不知道意义何在。
It's still not clear what the point was. Except that Abu Abed got whipsawed by two different phases of the war, the raid and interrogate phase, and the brotherhood phase.
现在仍不清楚意义何在。除了阿布·阿贝德被战争的两个不同阶段——搜捕审讯阶段和兄弟情谊阶段——左右为难之外。
The Sons of Iraq were widely loathed by the Iraqi government and its security forces. And they didn't keep their loathing to themselves. And Iraqi Army officer accused Abu Abed of killing one of his relatives. The US investigated, but could never confirmed that the man who'd allegedly been killed had ever existed. Other accusations against Abu Abed cropped up, some are still out there, unproven, but impossible to refute-- That he killed 35 Shiite civilians, that he beat an innocent man to death.
“伊拉克之子”被伊拉克政府及其安全部队广泛厌恶。他们并没有隐瞒这种厌恶。一名伊拉克军官指责阿布·阿贝德杀害了他的一名亲戚。美军调查过，但从未证实该被杀男子是否真的存在。针对阿布·阿贝德的其他指控也不断出现，有些至今仍然存在，无法证实，但也无法反驳——比如他杀害了35名什叶派平民，比如他将一名无辜者活活打死。
And then in November of 2007, a story came out in a British newspaper, The Guardian , that starred Abu Abed in the worst way. The reporter spent three days with him and painted a portrait of an arrogant, power hungry thug, kicking and slapping a man outside his house for a supposed insult, screaming at the security detail for Iraq's vice president, "Do you know who I am? Here I rule. I am the commander of Amariya. Did you dare to show your faces here before I kicked al-Qaeda out?" Also, interrogating a child about an alleged weapons cache. The lingering image from the article is Abu Abed's men holding him back as he tries to put his gun in the child's mouth.
然后，2007年11月，英国《卫报》刊登了一篇报道，以最糟糕的方式让阿布·阿贝德成为主角。记者与他共处了三天，描绘了一个傲慢、贪权暴徒的画像：在房子外因为所谓的侮辱踢打一名男子，对伊拉克副总统的安保人员尖叫：“你知道我是谁吗？这里我说了算。我是阿米里亚的指挥官。在我把基地组织赶走之前，你们敢在这里露面吗？”还审讯了一个孩子关于藏匿武器的情况。文章挥之不去的形象是：当阿布·阿贝德试图把枪塞进孩子嘴里时，他的手下在后面拉着他。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: I did not believe that that story was truthful. I thought it was embellished. Could I be wrong? Sure.
库尔上校：我不相信那篇报道是真实的。我认为它被夸大了。我可能错了吗？当然。
Colonel Kuehl published a long rebuttal to the story, saying the overall picture of Amiriyah it showed was wrong. The Sons of Iraq seemingly running rampant, with little or no supervision by the US military or the Iraqi military. His rebuttal did not, however, refute any of the specific incidents the story described. In fact, he concedes that some of them happened, though he doesn't believe Abu Abe put a gun in a child's mouth.
库尔上校发表了一篇长篇反驳，称其展示的阿米里亚的整体画面是错误的。“伊拉克之子”看似横行霸道，几乎没有受到美军或伊拉克军队的监管。然而，他的反驳并没有反驳文章所描述的任何具体事件。事实上，他承认其中一些确实发生了，尽管他不相信阿布·阿贝德把枪塞进了孩子的嘴里。
When the story came out, Kuehl was furious at Abu Abed. He believed Abu Abed's vanity, his desire to build up his own reputation as a tough guy, was putting the entire Sons of Iraq project at risk. He called Abu Abed in for a talk.
当报道传出时，库尔对阿布·阿贝德感到愤怒。他相信阿布·阿贝德的虚荣心，他想建立自己硬汉名声的愿望，将整个“伊拉克之子”项目置于风险之中。他把阿布·阿贝德叫去谈话。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: I was telling him, listen, I might have to remove you.
库尔上校：我告诉他，听着，我可能不得不解雇你。
Why didn't you?
你为什么没有这样做？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: People were very willing to report bad things going. Whether it was Abu Abed or somebody else. In this case, I got nothing. And so, why I didn't believe the story, and again, could I be wrong? Sure. But I just didn't have the evidence here other than the story. And am I right or wrong? I don't know. And there was one time we actually considered, is he the right guy for this?
库尔上校：人们非常乐于举报坏事。无论是针对阿布·阿贝德还是其他人。在这种情况下，我什么也没得到。所以，我不相信那篇报道，同样，我可能错了吗？当然。但我除了那篇报道之外没有任何证据。我是对是错？我不知道。有一次我们确实考虑过，他真的是合适人选吗？
What happened?
发生了什么？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: We came to the conclusion that this is the right guy.
库尔上校：我们得出的结论是，这确实是合适的人选。
This is Saad Motallebi again, the government adviser who talked earlier about how he worried they might lose control over Baghdad. He's talking about the Sons of Iraq, they were the crocodile he saw. Armed men, not under government control, roaming the streets. The US military had a solution to that. They thought the Iraqi government should absorb most of the Sons of Iraq into their security forces, the police and the army. Make those mostly Shiite forces represent the country as a whole, by adding Sunnis. But to many in the Iraqi government, the Sons of Iraq were insurgents, period. And its leaders like Abu Abed were former officers from Saddam Hussein's army.
这是萨阿德·莫塔勒比，就是那位之前谈到担心他们可能失去对巴格达控制的政府顾问。他在谈论“伊拉克之子”，那是他眼中的鳄鱼。武装人员，不受政府控制，在街上游荡。美军对此有一个解决方案。他们认为伊拉克政府应该将“伊拉克之子”的大部分成员纳入安全部队、警察和军队。通过增加逊尼派，让这些主要是什叶派的部队代表整个国家。但对于伊拉克政府中的许多人来说，“伊拉克之子”就是叛乱分子，句号。其领导人如阿布·阿贝德是萨达姆·侯赛因军队的前军官。
(SUBJECT) SAAD MOTALLEBI: The insurgency, they didn't fight for the new Iraq. That's the way we saw it. They fought for control over the region that they had previously control over.
萨阿德·莫塔勒比：叛乱分子，他们不是为新伊拉克而战。我们是这样看的。他们是为了重新控制他们之前控制的地区而战。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(SUBJECT) TRANSLATOR: The way that the government dealt with us was to just slowly squeeze us out.
翻译：政府对待我们的方式就是慢慢地把我们挤走。
Abu Abed says he and other Sons of Iraq wanted to form a police force in Amiriyah. He says they were prevented by the government.
阿布·阿贝德说他和“伊拉克之子”的其他成员想在阿米里亚建立一支警察部队。他说他们遭到了政府的阻挠。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
They appointed a police officer to lead the police station in our area, who was from the south.
他们任命了一名警察军官来领导我们地区的警察局，他是来自南部的人。
Meaning Shiite.
意思是什叶派。
And then they appointed his deputy, and then they appointed others who would work under him, all to make sure that we were squeezed out and that we wouldn't have any official capacity.
然后他们任命了他的副手，又任命了其他将在他手下工作的人，一切都是为了确保我们被挤走，我们不会有任何官方身份。
The Iraqi government essentially won this argument, in part because the US was eager to move on to a new phase of the war, the phase it's still in-- achieving political stability so the US forces can leave. What this meant for Abu Abed is that when he talked to US military guys, there was a new catch phrase, Iraqi sovereignty. Meaning, if the Iraqi government wants to put someone else in the police in this area, instead of you and your guys, that's their business and we're not going to intervene. He says this was different from what the US military had been saying to him before this point.
伊拉克政府实际上赢得了这场争论，部分原因是因为美军急于进入战争的下一阶段——即美军目前所处的阶段——实现政治稳定以便撤军。对阿布·阿贝德来说，这意味着当他与美军人员交谈时，出现了一个新的口头禅：“伊拉克主权”。意思就是，如果伊拉克政府想在这个地区安排其他人当警察，而不是你和你的手下，那是他们的事，我们不会干预。他说这与美军之前对他所说的话不同。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
One of the things that they said often was that you will have a place in the new Iraq. That they won't deal with you on a sectarian basis, that you will be included in this new leadership.
他们经常说的一件事就是你们在新伊拉克会有位置。他们不会基于宗派立场对待你，你会融入新的领导层。
And did you believe them that that was possible? And they could deliver that?
你相信他们说的是可能的吗？他们能兑现承诺吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
At the time? Yes.
当时吗？相信。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Why did I believe it? Because this was the force that brought down the previous regime in Iraq. This was the force that created the Iraqi government, that established the Iraqi army. Of course I believed it.
我为什么相信？因为这是推翻伊拉克前政权的部队。这是建立伊拉克政府、建立伊拉克军队的部队。我当然相信。
The more successful the Sons of Iraq were in neutralizing al-Qaeda, the less necessary they became. They made themselves obsolete. Kuehl saw this coming and tried to warn Abu Abed. Later, Kuehl led a big effort to try and get him to the US, rallied a network of churches and people and vouched for Abu Abed personally. But Kuehl was blunt with him when they were recruiting for the new police force in Amiriyah.
“伊拉克之子”在削弱基地组织方面越成功，他们的必要性就越低。他们让自己变得多余了。库尔预见到了这一点，并试图警告阿布·阿贝德。后来，库尔带头努力尝试让他进入美国，召集了一个教会和个人网络，并亲自为阿布·阿贝德作担保。但在阿米里亚招募新警察部队时，库尔对他很直率。
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: Did not really see him as a serious candidate to be the head of the security force.
库尔上校：并没有真正把他视为担任该安全部队负责人的严肃候选人。
You didn't?
你没有吗？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: I didn't. And we were actually trying to figure out who would be the right guy to do that, so.
库尔上校：我没有。我们实际上正在设法弄清楚谁才是做那件事的合适人选，所以……
Just so I understand fully, this is somebody you'd been working with for months, leading this group, trusting him, the bravest man you ever met, why not him?
为了完全理解，这是你已经共事了几个月、领导着这个组织、信任他、你见过最勇敢的人，为什么不是他？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: It goes back to what I think he was good at. I think he was a great fighter. I think he was great at-- very charismatic. I think he was the right guy to go fight al-Qaeda. I did not think he was the right guy and the right temperament to lead a police force of a community like that. He's a hot head.
库尔上校：这要回到我认为他擅长什么上来。我认为他是一名出色的战士。我认为他非常……非常有魅力。我认为他是去对付基地组织的正确人选。我不认为他拥有领导那样一个社区警察部队的正确性格。他是个暴脾气。
Meaning what?
意思是什么？
(SUBJECT) COLONEL DALE KUEHL: He has a temper. And it has caused him some problems that he is still having to deal with. We would not have rooted al-Qaeda out there without a guy like him, but I think there was a transition that needed to happen. Somebody that had a probably better temperament, that could deal with the politics of just being the leader of a community.
库尔上校：他有脾气。这导致了一些他仍然不得不处理的问题。没有像他这样的人，我们无法根除那里的基地组织，但我认为需要发生一次过渡。需要一个性格可能更好的人，能处理身为社区领袖的政治问题。
General Petraeus added a handwritten note to hit type-written letter of recommendation supporting Abu Abed's application to the US. The notes says, "He risked everything to stand against al-Qaeda in Iraq, and he's paid a heavy price. We should help him." He underlined should. A lot of Iraqis have helped the US and paid a heavy price. And we've turned many of them away for any blemish, or seeming blemish. And who has more blemishes on his record than a fighter? The Sons of Iraq, our alliance with them, was a big success for us. And this is the mess that goes along with it.
彼得雷乌斯将军在他为支持阿布·阿贝德赴美申请而写的打印推荐信上加了一行手写说明。便条说：“他冒着一切危险站出来反对伊拉克的基地组织，并付出了沉重的代价。我们应该帮助他。”他给“应该”加了下划线。很多伊拉克人帮助过美国并付出了沉重代价。而我们却因为任何污点或看似污点而拒绝了他们中的许多人。谁的记录能比一个战士有更多污点？“伊拉克之子”以及我们与他们的联盟，对我们来说是一个巨大的成功。而这正是随之而来的混乱。
Abu Abed's old neighborhood, Amiriyah, today is mostly calm, but bleak. Some of the buildings are pitted by gunfire and crumbling from bombings. There isn't a Sons of Iraq leader in Amiriyah anymore. Abu Abed's successor was blown up by a suicide bomber a few weeks before we got to Iraq. One of the few Sons of Iraq foot soldiers left in Amiriyah was working at the check point into the neighborhood. He hadn't been paid in two months.
阿布·阿贝德以前的社区——阿米里亚，今天大部分时间平静，但凄凉。一些建筑物被枪火击中，在轰炸中摇摇欲坠。阿米里亚不再有“伊拉克之子”的领导人了。阿布·阿贝德的继任者在我们到达伊拉克前几周被自杀式炸弹袭击者炸死了。阿米里亚仅存的少数“伊拉克之子”基层士兵之一正在社区检查站工作。他已经两个月没拿到工资了。
US and Iraqi officials say the Iraqi government has stalled on services in Amiriyah and others Sunni areas, in part to undermine the popularity of Sons of Iraq leaders. The US has been pushing reconciliation in Iraq, saying it's key to stabilizing the country. Trying to get Sunnis and Shiites, plus the Kurds, to work together and share power. It's not working. The Chief of the US reconciliation program in Baghdad told me.
美伊官员称，伊拉克政府在阿米里亚和其他逊尼派地区拖延提供服务，部分是为了削弱“伊拉克之子”领导人的声望。美国一直在推动伊拉克的和解，称其为稳定国家的关键。试图让逊尼派、什叶派和库尔德人共同努力、分享权力。但没用。巴格达美方和解项目负责人告诉我说。
Sons of Iraq, especially its leaders, have been arrested. Some are being killed, sometimes with their families, by al-Qaeda, by other rivals or enemies. Some, like Abu Abed, have fled. There's an arrest warrant out for him in Iraq now. Some US officials believe the charges are politically motivated. The cold fact is that Iraq may not need reconciliation to have stability, depending on how brutal the Iraqi government is willing to be, and we're willing to let them be. If they put enough Sunnis in prison, or drive them out of the country, while welcoming the few they do feel able to work with, the Shia majority might be able to run the country without ever reconciling with the Sunnis. Which might be fine with us, if Iraq were our only war. In Afghanistan, Afghan fighters have raised the issue of what's become of the the Sons of Iraq in meetings with the US, according to an American officer who served in Afghanistan.
“伊拉克之子”，特别是其领导人，已经被逮捕。有些人被基地组织、其他竞争对手或敌人杀害，有时连带家属一起。有些人，像阿布·阿贝德，已经逃离。现在伊拉克对他发出了逮捕令。一些美国官员认为这些指控是出于政治动机。冰冷的事实是，伊拉克可能不需要和解就能获得稳定，这取决于伊拉克政府愿意有多残暴，以及我们愿意让他们有多残暴。如果他们把足够多的逊尼派送进监狱，或者把他们赶出这个国家，同时欢迎那少数他们觉得能合作的人，什叶派多数派也许能运行这个国家，而无需与逊尼派和解。如果伊拉克是我们唯一的战争，那倒也没什么。据一位在阿富汗服役的美国军官称，在阿富汗，阿富汗战士曾在与美国的会议上提出过“伊拉克之子”后来结局的问题。
Everywhere we want local fighters to help us, they're going to ask themselves, how will we end up?
无论我们在哪里需要当地战士帮助我们，他们都会问自己：我们将会有什么样的结局？
Nancy Updike. Coming up, what is that crushed garbage under foot everywhere in Iraq cities? And other things that nobody has told you about life in Iraq today. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克。接下来，伊拉克城市里随处可见的被压扁的垃圾是什么？以及没人告诉过你的关于今天伊拉克生活的其他事情。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台（PRI）继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, Iraq After Us. Reporter Larry Kaplow and one of our producers, Nancy Updike, spent a month in Iraq this August as US troops were ending their combat mission. And they traveled around the country interviewing many, many more people than we will be able to fit into one hour today. To try to understand how things are going in Iraq, in this half hour of the show we are going to hear two more stories, two more acts from the stories that they gathered. And we are going to go straight from one to the other. And we're going to start with Act Two, Politics as Usual.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是“我们离开后的伊拉克”。记者拉里·卡普洛和我们的制片人南希·厄普代克在今年八月美军结束作战任务时在伊拉克待了一个月。他们走遍全国，采访了比我们今天一小时节目能容纳的要多得多的人。为了了解伊拉克的情况，在节目的下半部分，我们将听到另外两个故事，也就是他们收集到的另外两幕。我们将直接从一个过渡到另一个。我们将从第二幕开始：“一切照旧的政治”。
One of the biggest political challenges facing Iraq today has to do with something that's so basic, and that is that for decades the country was run by a dictator. And even before that dictator, before Saddam Hussein, there were other strongmen, and there were kings. Government in Iraq has basically meant somebody at the top imposing order and control on everybody below. And the United States has tried to convince Iraqis that democracy means distributing that power. Sending it out of Baghdad, out of these big, central ministries, and sending it all over the country. Giving political power to local mayors, and newly formed provincial councils. Iraq is divided into a bunch of provinces that are kind of like states.
今天伊拉克面临的最大政治挑战之一与一个非常基础的问题有关，那就是几十年来这个国家一直由独裁者统治。即使在那位独裁者——萨达姆·侯赛因之前，还有其他强人和国王。在伊拉克，政府基本上意味着上面的某个人对下面所有人强加秩序和控制。而美国一直试图说服伊拉克人，民主意味着分配那种权力。把它从巴格达、从这些大的核心部委里散出去，散到全国各地。把政治权力交给地方市长和新成立的省议会。伊拉克被划分为一堆省份，有点像州。
But Iraqis are not used to that. They're used to top down. Nancy and Larry went to Diyala Province, just north of Baghdad, to see whether the old mentality has changed at all. They started at the bottom rung in a top down government-- the mayor's office in Diyala's capital city Baqubah. Larry tells this story.
但伊拉克人对此不习惯。他们习惯于自上而下的方式。南希和拉里去了巴格达北部的迪亚拉省，看看旧心态是否有所改变。他们从自上而下的政府中最底层开始——迪亚拉首府巴古拜（Baqubah）的市长办公室。拉里来讲这个故事。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: The mayor's office is behind blast walls and barbed wire. And it's not really a municipal building, it's basically a large house at the end of a residential street. Inside there's a short dusty hallway with scuffed walls, in a small foyer with a few loose metal chairs. And it's filled with people, maybe 50 of them. People are literally pressed against a plexiglass divider at the end of the hall. An old woman shouts, "I'm not a dog, I'm a human being."
拉里·卡普洛（主持人）：市长办公室位于防爆墙和铁丝网后面。它并不是真正的市政建筑，基本上是住宅街尽头的一栋大房子。里面是一条短而布满灰尘的走廊，墙壁上有刮痕，还有一个放着几把松动金属椅的小门厅。挤满了人，可能有50个人。人们真的紧贴着走廊尽头的有机玻璃隔板。一位老妇人喊道：“我不是狗，我是人。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: Nancy, our interpreter Sarah, and I approach a man who tells us he was injured in a bombing back in 2006. He's a Shiite and they were usually the targets. After more than a dozen operations on his leg, a doctor classified him 70% disabled, and he can't work his farm. So he's here hoping to get a note from the mayor to help get compensation promised by the government.
拉里·卡普洛：南希、我们的翻译萨拉和我走近一个男人，他告诉我们他在2006年的一场爆炸中受伤。他是什叶派，他们通常是目标。在腿部经历了一打以上的手术后，医生将其评定为70%残疾，他无法再耕种农场。所以他来到这里希望得到一份市长的证明，以帮助获得政府承诺的赔偿。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
There is a million Iraqi dinar as a claim for my injury. It's been one year. I want to get this million, and no one give it to me.
关于我的伤情，有一百万伊拉克第纳尔的索赔。已经一年了。我想拿到这一百万，但没人给我。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: A million Iraqi dinars is about $850. The man with the leg injury, and everyone else here, wants to see the guy behind the plexiglass divider. It's kind of like The Wizard of Oz , they're hoping he can solve their problems. But when we get back to see Abdullah Al-Khayali, the mayor of this district of 500,000 people, it turns out, like the wizard, he's mostly powerless.
拉里·卡普洛：一百万伊拉克第纳尔大约是850美元。腿部受伤的男人和这里的所有人都想见见有机玻璃隔板后面的那个家伙。这有点像《绿野仙踪》，他们希望他能解决他们的问题。但当我们见到这个管辖50万人口地区的市长阿卜杜拉·阿尔-哈亚利（Abdullah Al-Khayali）时，结果发现，像那位巫师一样，他几乎毫无实权。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: Al-Khayali tells us he doesn't control what's happening on the city streets. The police force answers to the army, not to him. The schools and the hospitals are run from Baghdad. He can't authorise big public works projects. It's not so different from how it all worked under Saddam, and there's no plan for that to change. He still depends on the central government for almost all his money, too. Definitely no hospitality budget. He points to the table in front of us.
拉里·卡普洛：阿尔-哈亚利告诉我们，他无法控制城市街道上发生的事情。警察部队听命于军队，而不是他。学校和医院由巴格达运行。他不能批准大型公共工程项目。这与萨达姆统治下的运作方式并没有太大不同，而且也没有计划改变这一点。他仍然依赖中央政府来获取几乎所有的资金。当然也没有招待预算。他指着我们面前的桌子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
And for your information, too, this is a simple example, the tea, the water, it's all from my own money.
顺便告诉你，这是一个简单的例子，茶、水，全都是我自己的钱。
You mean the tea that we're drinking, the water, here on the table?
你是说我们喝的茶，水，这里桌子上的？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: He says the tea is no big deal, he's just trying to make a point. Al-Khayali in his mid-30's, and he's charming. Both times we see him, he's dressed like he is going to a nightclub instead of City Hall, in perfectly coordinated suits and ties and even socks. He's dapper, but beleaguered. Take the issue he says everyone's complaining to him about-- roadblocks. The Iraqi Army has barricaded all the roads into the center of town. They're meant to prevent car bomb attacks, but they've completely choked off the downtown.
拉里·卡普洛：他说茶没什么大不了的，他只是想说明一点。阿尔-哈亚利三十多岁，很迷人。我们两次见到他时，他穿得都像是去夜总会而不是市政厅，穿着完美搭配的西装、领带，甚至袜子。他衣冠楚楚，但饱受折磨。以大家都在抱怨的问题为例——路障。伊拉克军队封锁了通往市中心的所有道路。它们本意是防止汽车炸弹袭击，但彻底扼杀了市中心。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Yes, yes. They blocked it, and they stopped everybody from working and make living for their families.
是的，是的。他们封锁了它，阻止了每个人工作，无法为家人谋生。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
And without taking my order or ask me for it first, because I am here, the highest authority.
而且没有接受我的命令，也没有先问我，因为我在这里，是最高权威。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: Just imagine if an army blocked all the traffic to your downtown without consulting the mayor or anyone else.
拉里·卡普洛：想象一下，如果军队在没有咨询市长或任何其他人的情况下封锁了通往你们市中心的所有交通。
[SPEAKING  ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
I don't want to be proud, but really I am a social leader, and they make decisions without asking me or telling me about it.
我不想自大，但真的我是社会领袖，他们做出决定而不询问我或告诉我。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
And really I want them to hear this message.
我真的想让他们听到这个信息。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: One thing he does have a say in is who gets houses that the United Nations is giving away. They're supposed to go to refugees whose homes were destroyed. It's a US funded program to bring back people who fled the violence. But we heard he was giving some of the houses to relatives, even if they still had homes. So we ask Al-Khayali, expecting a sharp denial.
拉里·卡普洛：他唯一有话语权的一件事是联合国分发的房屋分配给谁。它们本应给那些家园被毁的难民。这是一个美国资助的项目，旨在带回逃离暴力的人。但我们听说他把一些房子分给了亲戚，即使他们还有家。所以我们问阿尔-哈亚利，期待着尖锐的否认。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Yes, many of these things happened.
是的，很多这类事情发生了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
I don't want to talk about ethics and say that I am a perfect man, yeah.
我不想谈论道德说我是个完美的人，是的。
(INTERVIEWER) LARRY KAPLOW: Are you saying that sometimes you do have to give houses to your friends and family because they pressure you?
拉里·卡普洛（采访者）：你是说有时你确实不得不把房子给朋友和家人，因为他们向你施压？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Not by force but--
不是强迫，但……
But by love. Calling you up and--
而是出于爱。他们打电话给你，而且……
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Yes, maybe they really pressure on me because maybe sometimes they wouldn't even do some work for me because I didn't give them the house.
是的，也许他们确实向我施压，因为也许有时他们甚至不会为我工作，因为我没有给他们房子。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: In Iraq, family comes first, because family might be the only thing you have to fall back on. All the other institutions are so fragile. The next rung up the government ladder, above City Hall, is the Provincial Council. If the provinces in Iraq are like states, the Provincial Council is like the State Legislature. The Council meets in a fancier building the mayor's office, much fancier. Tea and water flow freely. But that doesn't mean it works any better.
拉里·卡普洛：在伊拉克，家庭第一，因为家庭可能是你唯一可以依靠的东西。所有其他机构都太脆弱了。比市政厅高一级的政府梯子是省议会。如果伊拉克的省份像州，省议会就像州议会。理事会在比市长办公室更豪华的建筑里开会，豪华得多。茶水流淌。但这并不意味着它工作得更好。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
All the Provincial Council, no one of them served the citizen of Diyala. No one of them.
整个省议会，没有一个人服务过迪亚拉的公民。一个都没有。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: Meet Ahmer Thamer Mustafa Al-Khirke. He's a member of the Provincial Council, but he's mastered the political art of being outraged like he's some man on the street. Sarah couldn't keep a straight face as she was translating.
拉里·卡普洛：见见阿默·塔默·穆斯塔法·阿尔-基尔克（Ahmer Thamer Mustafa Al-Khirke）。他是省议会成员，但他掌握了像街头普通人一样愤慨的政治艺术。萨拉翻译时无法保持严肃。
He speaks too much.
他说得太多了。
I know, I know.
我知道，我知道。
The citizen of Diyala are disgusted by the situation of the Provincial Council.
迪亚拉的公民对省议会的状况感到厌恶。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
There's no electricity, no sewing  services.
没有电，没有服务。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
Garbage everywhere.
到处是垃圾。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: It was a fascinating interview. Picture Al-Khirke, a trim 54 year old in a dark suit, in the imperious bearing of the army general he was under the old regime. He had two main points he wanted to make. One, I live to serve the citizens of Diyala. In fact--
拉里·卡普洛：这是一次引人入胜的采访。想象一下阿尔-基尔克，一位54岁、穿着深色西装、举止威严的男人，带着他在旧政权下担任陆军将领的傲慢。他有两个主要的观点想表达。一，我活着就是为了服务迪亚拉的公民。事实上……
If I am not able to do or serve the people in Diyala, I will quit.
如果我没有能力做或服务迪亚拉的人民，我就辞职。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: And two, my allies and I refuse to me with the other members of the Council.
拉里·卡普洛：二，我的盟友和我拒绝与理事会的其他成员见面。
No we will not. We will not attend the meetings until they meet our demands.
不，我们不会。我们不会参加会议，直到他们满足我们的要求。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: We spent most of an hour trying to understand how Al-Khirke could serve the people of Diyala as an elected representative, without participating in the political body to which he was elected. But to Al-Khirke, this whole line of questioning was beside the point. What's important to him, is that his party didn't do well in local elections about two years ago. They got three out of 29 seats on the Provincial Council. But by early this year, the mood had shifted, and the party, lead nationally by Ayad Allawi, did very well in the national election, the one held this past spring to choose Iraq's new Parliament and Prime Minister. So Al-Khirke is threatening to call a do-over.
拉里·卡普洛：我们花了一个小时的大部分时间试图了解阿尔-基尔克如何能以民选代表身份服务迪亚拉人民，而不参与他所当选的政治机构。但对阿尔-基尔克来说，整个提问路线完全偏离了重点。对他重要的是，他的政党在大约两年前的地方选举中表现不好。他们在省议会29个席位中只占了3个。但到今年年初，情绪发生了转变，而由阿亚德·阿拉维（Ayad Allawi）领导的该政党在全国选举中表现非常好，即今年春天举行以选择伊拉克新议会和总理的那次选举。所以阿尔-基尔克威胁要进行重选。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(SUBJECT) TRANSLATOR: And we will make a new election here in Baqubah.
翻译：我们将在这里，巴古拜，进行一场新的选举。
Why? But why?
为什么？但为什么？
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: It's as if the Republicans in America looked at their poll numbers and asked for a do-over of the 2008 Presidential election right now.
拉里·卡普洛：就好像美国的共和党人看着他们的民调数字，要求现在就进行2008年总统大选的重选。
But that's the way elections work. But that's the way elections work, you don't get to say when the election comes, when you're popular. You have to wait for the four years, right?
但那是选举运作的方式。但那是选举运作的方式，你不能说当选举到来时，当你受欢迎时。你必须等待四年，对吧？
No. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
不。（阿拉伯语对话）
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: He's saying, "No, the law says that if a third of the Provincial Council wants a new election, they can petition the Parliament to call a new election." Which is true, but trying to do that would throw Diyala into many more months of paralysis and drift, which is what the bombers and militants want, too. They've killed 381 people and wounded over 1,000 in Diyala so far this year.
拉里·卡普洛：他说，“不，法律规定，如果省议会三分之一的人想要新选举，他们可以请愿议会呼吁新选举。”这是真的，但试图那样做会使迪亚拉陷入更多的瘫痪和漂泊中，这正是炸弹客和武装分子也想要的。他们今年在迪亚拉已经杀死了381人，伤者超过1000人。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
God willing, we will solve all these problems and we will find the solutions for all troubles in Iraq.
如果上帝保佑，我们将解决所有这些问题，我们将找到解决伊拉克所有麻烦的办法。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: This is politics in Iraq today. All these institutions are so new and so weak, and the politicians don't see the point of working together and compromising. For them, you're either in charge or you're not. Like in the old Iraq. And if that's your mentality, with everything in flux, if you're not on top, the most sensible strategy is to stall until power shifts again.
拉里·卡普洛：这就是当今伊拉克的政治。所有这些机构都如此新且如此脆弱，政客们根本不认为合作和妥协有什么意义。对他们来说，你要么掌权，要么不掌权。就像旧伊拉克一样。如果那是你的心态，在一切都不确定的情况下，如果你不在高位，最明智的策略就是拖延，直到权力再次转移。
Act Three, Today in Babylon. Iraq is stable now. In geo-political terms, Iraq is stable. We saw that when we were there. Kids go to school. People with money go out to dinner and take vacations. Men go hit the night clubs in Baghdad and drink beer. Young couples have fancy deafening weddings.
第三幕，“今日巴比伦”。伊拉克现在稳定了。用地缘政治术语来说，伊拉克是稳定的。我们在那里时看到了这一点。孩子们去上学。有钱人出去吃饭和度假。男人们去巴格达的夜总会喝啤酒。年轻夫妇举行奢侈震耳欲聋的婚礼。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: But stable in Iraq just means it's not flying into pieces anymore. Stable means stable enough for us, the rest of the world. For people who live there, it's still dangerous, frightening, and just plain difficult. There aren't enough jobs. Huge numbers of people survive on a couple of days of work a month, or they live off relatives. Officials expect bribes for everything, passports, business permits, police protection. The prisons are horrific.
拉里·卡普洛：但伊拉克的“稳定”只是意味着它不再分崩离析。稳定意味着对我们、对世界其他地方来说足够稳定。对于住在这里的人来说，这里仍然危险、可怕，而且纯粹是困难。没有足够的工作。大量人口靠每月几天的工作生存，或者靠亲戚养活。官员们对每一件事都索要贿赂：护照、营业执照、警察保护。监狱令人恐怖。
There isn't enough clean water. The entire country is carpeted with trash that seems to be 90% flattened water bottles. And there are still bombings and killings. 200 to 300 dead per month. That's a tenth of what it was three years ago. But imagine if a dozen or more people were being blown up by bombs each month in any US city, for seven years. You don't get used to it. Iraqis haven't developed some special mid-East super immunity to violence just because they've seen a lot of it. Larry and I talked to so many people who were just exhausted by relentless, low-level fear.
没有足够的清洁用水。整个国家铺满了垃圾，似乎90%是压扁的水瓶。而且仍然有爆炸和杀戮。每月有200到300人死亡。这只是三年前的十分之一。但想象一下，如果任何美国城市每月都有十几个人甚至更多被炸死，持续七年。你不会习惯它的。伊拉克人并没有因为看到太多暴力就产生了某种特殊的中东超级免疫力。拉里和我与很多人交谈，他们只是被无休止、低水平的恐惧搞得筋疲力尽。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: So we made it our mission to seek out people who are happy and plowing ahead in spite of at all. We stopped in at a shop in Abu Abed's old neighborhood, Amiriyah.
拉里·卡普洛：所以我们的使命是寻找那些尽管如此仍然快乐并不断前进的人。我们在阿布·阿贝德以前的社区——阿米里亚的一家店里停了下来。
It was full of women, and stocked floor to ceiling with herbal remedies of every kind including--
里面满是妇女，从地板到天花板堆满了各种各样的草药，包括……
Snake oil.
蛇油。
Snake oil makes long hair for the women, and it's so good to make the hair strong.
蛇油让妇女的头发变长，这对让头发强韧非常好。
An actual snake oil salesman. His shop was clearly a hub for women in the neighborhood. He joked around with them while he told them how to take the medicines, threw English in.
一个真正的蛇油推销员。他的店显然是社区妇女的中心。他一边告诉她们如何服用药物，一边和她们开玩笑，甚至夹杂着英语。
One before breakfast, one before lunch, and then I'll welcome my sister.
早餐前一颗，午餐前一颗，然后我就欢迎我的姐妹。
After the women left, I started to ask my first question.
妇女们离开后，我开始问我的第一个问题。
How are things in Amiriyah now? How is Amiriyah now?
阿米里亚现在情况如何？阿米里亚现在怎么样？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
(SUBJECT) TRANSLATOR: He said, I want to check, because one of the ladies left here a bag. I need to check it.
翻译：他说，我想核对一下，因为刚才有一位女士在这里留下了一个包。我需要检查它。
He was checking her bag to make sure she hadn't left a bomb behind.
他正在检查她的包，以确保她没有留下炸弹。
My friends with the women-- [SPEAKING ARABIC]
我和女人们的朋友——（阿拉伯语对话）
(SUBJECT) TRANSLATOR: She is my friend, but I also got my suspicions about it.
翻译：她是我的朋友，但我对她也有怀疑。
Within five minutes, he was telling us how during the worst of the violence, three years ago, his older brother had been kidnapped and the family impoverished itself to pay $17,000 ransom.
五分钟内，他就告诉我们，在三年前暴力最严重的时候，他的哥哥被绑架，家庭为了支付17000美元的赎金而变得贫困。
We sold many things, our car, another shop, everyone from my sister's and sister-in-law's gold, we sold it.
我们卖了很多东西，我们的车，另一家店，每个人从我姐妹和弟媳的金饰，我们都卖了。
They killed him anyway.
他们还是杀了他。
And we asked them, why you killed him? His name is Hussein.
我们问他们，为什么杀他？他的名字叫侯赛因。
Hussein is the name of a Shiite saint. He was killed by a Shiite militia.
侯赛因是什叶派圣徒的名字。他被什叶派民兵杀了。
They said, he's a Sunni and he's a Dulami.
他们说，他是逊尼派，他是杜拉米（Dulami）。
Dulami, his last name, is the name of a large Sunni tribe in Iraq. The man started to cry, and went to the back of the shop to collect himself.
杜拉米，他的姓氏，是伊拉克一个大逊尼派部落的名字。那个男人开始哭泣，走到店后面去整理情绪。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: We didn't give up on our mission, but the reality was almost any person we talked to in Iraq was only one or two questions away from despair. Even our translator, Sarah, who was always sunny and joking around, broke down during an interview. It happened after a man we were talking to, a Sons of Iraq leader in Diyalah, plucked a tissue out of a box to make a point.
拉里·卡普洛：我们没有放弃我们的使命，但现实是我们在伊拉克交谈的几乎任何一个人，距离绝望只有一两个问题的距离。即使是我们的翻译萨拉，她总是很开朗、喜欢开玩笑，在一次采访中也崩溃了。那发生在我们要交谈的一个人——迪亚拉的一位“伊拉克之子”领导人从盒子里抽出一张纸巾来说明观点之后。
I'm sorry. He says the American forces use us like a tissue. I feel the same thing. I'm sorry.
抱歉。他说美国军队用我们就像用一张纸巾一样。我也感觉同样。抱歉。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: Sarah was an interpreter for the US Army during the surge. And she was wrongly accused of aiding the insurgents, put in prison, and by the time the charges were dropped, she'd been blacklisted and couldn't go back to work for the US, one of the few decent paying jobs in Iraq. She's the only bread winner for two boys. Her husband was killed because of her work with the Americans.
拉里·卡普洛：萨拉是增兵期间美军的口译员。她被错误地指控协助叛乱分子，被关进监狱，当指控被撤销时，她被列入黑名单，不能再为美国工作，这是伊拉克为数不多的收入不错的工作之一。她是两个男孩唯一的养家糊口者。她的丈夫因为她与美国人的工作而被杀。
We went to what seems to be the happiest place in Baghdad. Zawra park, which is a big amusement park, with rides and places to picnic. In the rest of Baghdad this summer, you might get an hour a day of city electricity. But Zawra park is always lit up, like any carnival midway. It was packed with groups of young single men and families.
我们去了巴格达似乎最快乐的地方。扎瓦拉（Zawra）公园，那是一个很大的游乐园，有游乐设施和野餐的地方。在今年夏天巴格达的其他地方，你可能每天只有一小时的市政用电。但扎瓦拉公园总是灯火通明，像任何狂欢节的中途点。这里挤满了年轻单身男子和家庭。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: One family was having a night-time birthday picnic, with cake and candles, for one of the women's two-year old granddaughter.
拉里·卡普洛：一个家庭正在进行夜间生日野餐，有蛋糕和蜡烛，为了其中一位妇女的两岁孙女。
We came here today to just sort of escape from the lack of water, and the lack of electricity. Just to come here to have fun, to have a change of atmosphere. To celebrate. To smile.
我们今天来这里只是为了逃避缺水和缺电。只是为了来这里玩，换一种气氛。庆祝。微笑。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: The park costs money. The cake and the outing were a big deal for this family. They are Shiites from Sadr city, the poorest part of Baghdad.
拉里·卡普洛：公园是要钱的。蛋糕和出游对这个家庭来说是一件大事。他们是来自巴格达最贫穷地区——萨德尔城（Sadr City）的什叶派。
We are just laborers, day by day. Basically if we get paid, then we eat and we drink and things like that. If we don't have a job-- you know labor is a day by day job. If you get a job, it's great. If you don't, you know.
我们只是劳工，一天一天过。基本上如果我们得到报酬，我们就吃饭、喝水之类。如果我们没有工作——你知道劳动力是一天一天的工作。如果你有工作，那太棒了。如果你没有，你知道。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: Of course, this being Iraq, where hospitality to strangers is a national creed, the family insisted we join them for cake. And we were two minutes in, I clocked it, when they started telling us there version of the snake oil man's story. An aunt, chased down and killed by some of her Sunni neighbors, the rest of the family driven out of their home.
拉里·卡普洛：当然，这里是伊拉克，对陌生人的热情好客是一种国家信条，这家人坚持让我们加入他们吃蛋糕。而我们才两分钟，我计时了，他们就开始给我们讲他们版本的蛇油男人的故事。一位阿姨被一些逊尼派邻居追赶并杀害，剩下的家人被赶出家园。
Even our neighbors were trying to kill us. They were waiting for us at the end of the street. My neighbor from the other side had called me and told me that, "You should leave immediately." So I took my boys, and my husband, and we left the area.
甚至我们的邻居都在试图杀死我们。他们在街尽头等着我们。我另一边的邻居打电话告诉我，“你应该立即离开。”所以我带着我的孩子们和丈夫，离开了那个地区。
I asked them what they thought about the US. These were people who had been terribly oppressed under Saddam Hussein. At the same time, many more Shiite civilians have been killed in the last seven years than Sunnis or American troops. The woman I was talking to clammed up, and had to be coaxed by our translator. Finally she said--
我问他们对美国有什么看法。这些人曾在萨达姆·侯赛因统治下受到严重压迫。与此同时，在过去七年里，被杀害的什叶派平民比逊尼派或美国士兵要多得多。我谈话的那个女人沉默了，不得不用我们的翻译哄劝。最后她说……
Basically, I don't want to give you the truth, because I don't want you to be disappointed or upset, because I don't want you to feel that I'm degrading your country or anything like that.
基本上，我不想告诉你真相，因为我不想让你感到失望或难过，因为我不想让你觉得我在贬低你的国家之类的。
I said, "Let me have it."
我说，“说吧。”
We see Americans as the enemy. As they came in, they were the enemy, because as you might know, or might heard, you saw all the killing in the streets and the kidnapping and the ransoms. They're the enemy. I mean, there's no point. I mean I can't emphasize enough to you how much that they hurt the Iraqi community. We were under the impression that they would pick up the pieces, they would put everything together again, but instead they shattered it.
我们把美国人看作敌人。当他们进入时，他们就是敌人，因为正如你可能知道或可能听到的，你看到了街上所有的杀戮、绑架和赎金。他们是敌人。我是说，没有意义。我是说，我无法向你充分强调他们对伊拉克社区造成了多大伤害。我们原以为他们会收拾残局，他们会把一切重新组合在一起，但相反，他们把它震碎了。
There's a quote from the US military's counter-insurgency manual, the text book for the strategy that help turned the Iraq war around. It says, "Sometimes societies are most prone to unrest, not when conditions are the worse, but when the situation begins to improve and people's expectations rise." The worst violence in Iraq ended about two years ago. But in those two years, Iraqis haven't seen their daily life improve at all. Their relief at not being in constant danger has worn off, and now they want more than just survival. They want to move forward with their lives. But they can't.
美军反叛乱手册中有一句话，那本帮助扭转伊拉克战争局势的教科书。它说：“有时社会最容易发生动荡，不是在条件最糟糕时，而是在局势开始好转、人们的期望值上升时。”伊拉克最严重的暴力大约在两年前结束了。但在那两年里，伊拉克人根本没有看到他们的日常生活有任何改善。他们不再处于持续危险中的那种解脱感已经消退，现在他们想要的不仅仅是生存。他们想要继续他们的生活。但他们做不到。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: We did eventually find someone who didn't cry. A soft spoken man named Faraz Khaldoon with a shiny spacious store, full of ice cream soda and canned goods from Syria and Turkey. Even condiments from the US. But even him, when we ask him how it's going, he says with a laugh--
拉里·卡普洛：我们最终找到了一个没有哭的人。一个说话轻声细语、名叫法拉兹·哈尔敦（Faraz Khaldoon）的男人，他有一家光鲜宽敞的店，摆满了来自叙利亚和土耳其的冰淇淋苏打和罐头食品。甚至还有来自美国的调味品。但即使是他，当我们问他情况如何时，他笑着说……
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
（阿拉伯语对话）
About 85% bad.
大约85%的情况很糟糕。
(HOST) LARRY KAPLOW: In the six months since he opened his shop, two bombs have gone off nearby, one of them shattering his windows. The city's decrepit power grid surged and started a fire in the store. And bombings in the market downtown led the Iraqi Army to close off a bunch of the roads. So when he tries to restock his store, to run his business, it takes a Rube Goldberg series of motorbikes and trucks.
拉里·卡普洛：在他开店的六个月里，附近发生了两次爆炸，其中一次震碎了他的窗户。城市破旧的电网激增，在店里引起了一场火灾。市中心的爆炸导致伊拉克军队封锁了多条道路。所以当他试图重新进货，经营生意时，这需要一系列鲁布·戈德堡式的摩托车和卡车。
He told us the same thing a lot of people did. The snake oil salesman, our translator Sarah, people in the mayor's office, the park and stores, hardworking middle-class people. He wants to leave Iraq. Most of these people won't be able to leave. But they want to. And there are a lot of them.
他告诉我们很多人都说过同样的话。蛇油推销员、我们的翻译萨拉、市长办公室里的人、公园和商店里的人、勤劳的中产阶级。他想离开伊拉克。这些人中的大多数无法离开。但他们想。而且他们不在少数。
Our program today was reported in Iraq by Larry Kaplow and Nancy Updike, produced by our senior producer, Julie Snyder, and Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Shawn Wen.
我们今天的节目由拉里·卡普洛和南希·厄普代克在伊拉克报道，由我们的资深制片人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、萨拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞门（Robyn Semien）和阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）参与。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。肖恩·温（Shawn Wen）提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is not just our boss. He is not just a great public radio professional. He is also a part time professional mind reader.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。你知道，他不仅是我们的老板。他不仅仅是一位伟大的公共广播专业人士。他也是一位兼职职业读心术者。
Your thoughts are very nice.
你的想法非常好。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。